قال وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي بنيجانس ان
الفكره من وراء ما جرى الاتفاق عليه بين
حزب اللكود ورئيس حزب العظمه اليهوديه هي
خلق جيش خاص لاثمار بن كثير في الضفه
الغربيه على نحو نشكل خطوره على تفعيل
قوات الجيش ويخلقوا مشاكل امنيه حقيقيه
وصفها بانها اشبه بعمليه ارهابيه
واضاف جانسي في تغريده انه لا يمكن رؤيته
هذا الاتفاق الا من باب ان نتنياهو يعترف
بان رئيس الحكومه الحقيقي سيكون بنك كثير
نفسه
بسعي الى تفكيك صلاحيات الحكومه الى شضايا
من الوزارات على نحو ان يقود اسرائيل الى
خطر امنيا حقيقي
فلسطينيه اكدت وزاره الخارجيه الفلسطينيه
انها تنظر بخطوره بالغه لتداعيات اتفاقات
نتنياهو مع اليمين المتطرف وممثلي
مواصفاته بالفاشيه الاسرائيليه حسب وصفها
وقالت الوزراء انها تحذر من نتائج هذه
الاتفاقيات على ساحه الزراعه وخصوصا
صلاحيات التي يمنحها نتنياهو لبن كثير
فيما يتعلق بالاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله
والاستيطان
وحذرت الوزاره من انعكاسات الاتفاقات على
اي جهود الاقليميه ودوليه تبذل من اجل
التهدئه كما طالبه الوزراء المجتمع
الدوليه تحمل مسؤولياته لمتابعه هذه
التطورات والضغط على الحكومه الاسرائيليه
المقبله لضمان عدم تنفيذ سياساتها
العنصريه بشان القضيه الفلسطينيه
من القدس ينضم الينا مراسل الجزيره الياس
كرام الياس اتفاق بين نتنياهو وحزب العظمه
اليهوديه ماذا يعني ذلك وما هي ردود الفعل
حتى الان
ميه الاصوليه الدينيه
اليوم سيمهد في قادم الايام الى توقيعي
مزيد من الاتفاقات
الدينيه المتشدده وهو يحاصر بطبيعه الحال
ايضا
الذي مازال يتعنته في الحقائب التي سوف
تسند اليه لكن واضح بان هذا الاتفاق اليوم
يعبر عن شكل هذه الحكومه اليمنيه المتطرفه
يشكل الجناح الاكثر تطرفا ااه فيها ونشير
هنا الى انها بين فير كان يحتاجه حتى هذا
اليوم يحتاج الى اذن من الشرطه
الاسرائيليه من اجل التنفيذ الاقتحامات
على راس المستوطنين لباحات المسجد الاقصى
المبارك وهو سيعطيها بعد سيعطي هذا الاذن
للمستوطنين بعد ان يصبح وزيرا للامن
القومي كما انه كان يح الى اذن من الشرطه
الاسرائيليه من اجل القيام وال- اا القيام
بمظاهرات الاستفزازيه في مدينه القدس
المحتله وكذلك في بؤر الصراع والاحتكاك مع
الفلسطينيين وهو من سيعطي هذا الاذن بعد
ان يصبح وزيرا للامن القومي بجفير سيتولى
هذه الحقيبه مع صلاحيات الموسعه ايه
ستمنحه ايضا الاشراف على همم فرقه حرس
الحدود في الضفه الغربيه المحتله كما هو
معروف بان حرس الحدود هي من صلاحياتي وزير
الامن الداخلي لكن الان سوف تصبح هذه
الوحدات العامله في الضفه الغربيه المحتله
تحت امره وليس تحت امرته وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي كما هو معمول به حتى اليوم
وهذا ما يدعو الى مخاوف همم وزير الدفاع
الحالي الذي قال بان هذا الاتفاق عمليا
جيشا خاصا له في الضفه الغربيه المحتله
على نحو شكله خطرا امنيا ايه على اسرائيل
وعلى تفعيل قوات جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
في الضفه الغربيه المحتله كما ان بن جرير
ستكون له صلاحيات ايضا على اداره ما يعرف
بالدوريات الخضراء التي تلاحق الفلسطينيين
في صحراء النقب وتسعى الى تدمير منازلهم
وعشائرهم نحن نتحدث عن عشرات القرى
الفلسطينيه في صحراء النقب التي لا تعترف
اسرائيل بوجودها ومن فيدير يريد ان يلاحق
هؤلاء الفلسطينيين ويجمعهم ضمن حي الزنديه
في صحراء شكرا جزيلا